we do have uh and in shabbat with us
congratulations uh shabba a great game
for you with the black pieces how did
you approach it you were having a a
difficult tournament up to that point uh
yeah for some reason uh
you know
cannot find my flow until this game and
i
tried a lot of different things
you know i played almost non-stop for a
month before this uh this tournament i
played in uh
world team seniors in italy and then i
played world open and i was hoping that
i'll be here
at least at least not rusty but
well didn't work out so far
but uh
today well thanks to nick's blunders uh
you know
a lot of traveling for you also uh was
uh you playing tennis because we met in
the elevator and you're just coming back
from tennis against ray robson right
make a difference oh ray
excellent yeah excellent player by the
way he's a
college level player and
well
beats me so it took him took him two
hours to
beat me in a whole match so you know i
was holding it for a while
and uh
did that give you any confidence for
today's game uh it's more like watching
uh wimbledon final this morning that's
what gave me the confidence yeah this
look and how uh
composed and uh confident that
uh novak djokovic was yeah that that was
the inspiration perfect let's take a
look at today's game because it was uh
definitely confident uh from your part
despite the fact that you were getting
viciously attacked
did you feel that way
uh
yes i i didn't really have to allow all
this if
uh bishop g5 was a really gamble i could
have just
probably taken d5 and take and take on
a2
i did not really see a refutation of
that
just black is up upon it feels pretty
safe and take another one on b2
i know maybe
can he force a draw probably not you
have queen before
uh
quinn d4 yeah i i know it looks like
white doesn't really have a lot of
threats for two points and uh but i
thought
i didn't want to give nick positional
compensation the plan for a game was uh
to get him into
like a
tactical militant and uh
so according to nick himself he he
blundered queen b6 okay and the whole
idea that
quinn will get to e3 and controlled h6
but in fact it was still within the
margins of equality at this point really
yes so knight to f5
okay queen to d3
and i think king to f2 was the big
mistake into g1 still maintains equality
what was your plan after king to g1
how's that possible uh
[Laughter]
no okay i wanted to pick up both pawns
and come back is that possible perhaps
yes okay
wait just once
you can enjoy the g3 right can i go to
g3 wait wait wait when you when you are
on b2
i think i can go to g3 there's no more
checks uh oh no then i don't wanna
okay uh
no i i okay let me
stop here for a second uh
okay i need to control h6 if i don't
want to draw right precisely right and
queen to d2 was probably the most
difficult uh move to answer for white
but after queen to d2 queen to h4
perhaps we can go into that line yes sir
no no after kg1
okay and now knight takes d6 to distract
the queen
from the defense of uh the c1 h6 that oh
i'm in
yeah what can you do
oh wow
yeah i i must admit i didn't see all
that i thought at this point i was
winning but after king f2 you definitely
found uh the best moves almost best
moves did you consider rook bc8
this was a nice move that we saw rook b
to c8 rook bc8 instead of bishop take c4
oh
yeah i'm controlling h6 so there's no
and now this is over also
the best he can do is take on g6 and
go into that losing end game other than
coin for a lot of for a lot of pieces
yeah
but still bishop b4 uh keeps the
advantage and now you found this
brilliant move e4
uh
yeah so the rook can lift and uh
yeah basically i thought that like
no threats uh no immediate threats for
white so i should consolidate and uh
but uh
i think our main consideration started
to defend extremely well for like kind
of
started finding those only moves and uh
we we were surprised by queen b2 we
expected you to follow it up with rook
before
b5 i mean right away yeah we thought
that this was your intention so queen b2
was a was a surprise for us
okay well
i wanted to pick up like few pawns
[Laughter]
which we admire
quality
yes and
now as usual yeah the
i made it more difficult for myself and
we like the king chase at the end though
yeah i couldn't decide at which point i
want to play rook c8 and uh finally
by the way sorry to interrupt this one
is over christopher eu takes down
andrew hung in the battle of the leaders
in the junior section wow yeah what a
game
uh
yeah i was surprised
oh he
okay can he go king h5 but
i was like
completely losing no i yeah i can simply
trade questions
yeah that's uh
so nick decided to make it into interest
in the end you know the
spectator friendly and
spectators family
um
that was uh nice of him yeah
alex congratulations a big victory for
you who do you have tomorrow
i have no clue
taking it one
one game at the time any any tennis uh
matches uh schedules tonight uh
a little warmer than it was yesterday so
i don't know
basically if it's below uh below 90 we
should play was right but uh i don't
know what it is all right well
we'll let you go check that out and
maybe schedule a tennis match good luck
all right thank you
thank you uh shabbat that's always nice
to see a king hunt i